You are not limited to using DesignaKnit
or the PC 10 controller for stitch
patterns on electronics
Silver Reed knitting machines.
Combined Cochenile Stitch Painter and
the Silver Knit pattern controller for a
powerful, easy to use alternative.
If you want to follow along, make sure
that you're familiar with the basics of
Stitch Painter.
Follow the instructions for installing the
Silver Knitt utility software and connect
all the cables.
Let's explore this powerful combination
of tools that will change how you use your
knitting machine.
Click the shortcut to
the Silver Knit utility.
A simple interface is displayed.
It opens with the last
file that you worked with.
Let's open a new Ptitch Painter file.
Click browse and select
your file ending with STC.
The first thing you'll notice is a
preview of the stitch you selected.
The number of stitches and rows are
indicated as well as the knitting method.
We'll talk about the knitting
method in another tutorial.
Click the preview button for a larger
image and you can examine exactly what
information will download to the Silver
Knit controller and then to your knitting
machine.
At the top is shown the stitch pattern
that you just selected at the bottom is
shown the stitch pattern that
currently resides in the controller.
Now you'll click download to transfer the
design created in Stitch Painter that you
just uploaded to the
Silver KNit controller.
Before the download starts, you have
a number of options for modifying and
personalizing the stitch pattern.
We'll discuss these later.
For now, accept the defaults,
select your machine and click OK.
You'll see a progress bar as the
pattern is downloaded to the controller.
When the download is complete,
you'll see your pattern name shown.
Click knit to start knitting.
Here is the Silver Knit
interactive kitting screen.
Your entire pattern is shown in color
with row number indicators on the left.
As you move your carriage back and forth,
your patterning needles are selected.
Notice the directional
indicators on each side.
Now if you need to go back or rip a
few rows, you can do it here on screen.
Just click the row where
you'd like to start knitting.
Other tutorials about using Stitch Painter
and the Silver Knit pattern controller are
available in the Knit
it Now learning library.
Please consider purchasing Stitch Painter
and the Silver Knit pattern controller by
clicking the links.